several East Asian countries are on high
alert after North Korea's newest threat
Japan and South Korea say they will
reshape their militaries in response
there are calls for more powerful
weapons to defend themselves but the
most important response will come from
China
North Korea's main patron Ben Tracy is
in Beijing where the government has a
lot at stake
Ben good morning good morning we
actually just received this response
from the Chinese government and in it
they say the situation on the Korean
Peninsula is highly sensitive we hope
the parties will be cautious with words
and behavior and stop provoking each
other and avoid escalation now the
Chinese government fears that this war
of words could lead to a regional arms
race and that already appears to be
happening South Korean president moon
jae-in is calling for a complete
overhaul of South Korea's military in
the face of North Korea's rapidly
evolving nuclear capabilities in Japan
some lawmakers are pushing for new
weapons that could launch a preemptive
strike now keep in mind China just
agreed this past weekend to go along
with the UN sanctions on Kim Jong Un's
regime which will largely be up to China
to enforce having the President of the
United States throw more fuel on this
fire may make China think twice about
how far down the road it wants to go in
supporting US actions on North Korea now
next week North Korea celebrates its
Liberation Day and some analysts have
said that that might be an opportunity
for Kim Jong moon to launch yet another
missile or conduct his country's sixth
underground nuclear test what Ben Tracy
in Beijing thank you